Hello Freak bitches.
That whole system.
You've never been divorced,
right?
I have.
You know,
as soon as you enter it,
you see right away that the whole thing is stacked against us and it's,
this is,
you know,
it's just look into it.
If you don't believe me,
I mean you have to basically friends and I went to a mile this divorce,
I mean my ex wife was as as easy on me as you could be,
but nonetheless,
I ended up paying a lot more child support than she really deserved.
And very,
but not a lot.
I mean,
but it was a lot of men.
Oh,
in fact,
you would do have a friend just happened to I think,
right?
Yeah.
You go into these courtrooms and it's basically down to a judge as to a friend
who has to pay alimony for the rest of his life.
Yeah.
He was married for 12 years.
He's been divorced for 14 he still has to pay his ex wife.
He's married to a new woman.
He has a new family.
He didn't even have kids with this woman.
He has to pay her forever and forever.
Imagine if till she dies.
Imagine if they had kids.
He'd fucked her so hard.
She can't work anymore forever.
How about that?
[inaudible] that's a crazy lot to say about that,
but yeah,
but uh,
that's a crazy law and they have,
when there's kids involved,
right?
Forget it.
That that's a very sexist law by the way,
because that's law is implying that this woman is incapable of making it on her
own.
Thank you.
By definition,
it's antifeminist antifeminist and it is sexist and it's patriarchal.
It's totally patriarchal.
Women who support it,
they're supporting it because they don't like men.
I mean,
that literally would lose what it is.
Who knows?
I don't know about,
listen,
if you're supporting a woman,
never having to work again because she married a guy for a certain amount of
time,
like relationships come and go.
People get tired of each other and people have the right to change.
You shouldn't be financially obligated to take care of someone for the rest of
their life just because you were married at one point in time.
That's crazy.
Completely agree with you.
Especially in today's Day and age where my friend is 54 I think he is now.
He could live to be a hundred so what the fuck he's got to pay for her for
another 46 years.
That's insanity.
Phenomenal.
Yeah,
but again,
that's,
I agree with you completely,
but what you said just then about it being sexist,
it is.
That's a radical concept that hasn't even,
I think,
registered with most people and if many people heard it,
they would think you are a sexist yourself for saying it,
but you know what?
It is inescapable that that's what's going on that says I'm against men is very
common.
It's sexism against women too.
That's what we're also saying and that's the radical part of this,
right?
It's actually patriarchal in the most fundamental sense,
which is that the court is saying that the man should be the provider.
I'm going to tell you a story.
There's a woman in Florida who was,
is a bit in my act and I'm doing now.
It's a true story.
There's a woman in Florida was a cop.
She was 25 years old.
She pretended to be a high school student and she's attractive woman,
made friends with this boy.
He thought it was his girlfriend and she talked him into selling her pot and
then she arrested him.
That only works when you have a 17 year old boy and a 25 year old woman.
If you had a 25 year old man throwing dick,
your 17 year old daughter,
and then he gets her to sell him pot and then
he arrests.
Or there would be people lining the fucking street with torches to kill that
guy.
But people are sexist against boys.
They fill that boy should just keep it in his pants.
That boy should know better.
And you know as well as I know when you're 17 years old,
you are uh,
baffled bag of hormones with a boner just running through the world trying to
figure out what the fuck's going on and you're 12 months away from being an
adult.
It's chaos.
It's craziness to end to think that this young boy cause should be able to think
clearly in that moment while there's 25 year old woman has manipulating him is
insane.
But they allowed it.
And this kid has a felony on his fucking record
right now.
Yup.
This is,
this is the root of the issue with feminism.
That is current feminism.
It's its current incarnation.
I am a feminist by the way.
How dare you can define that.
Leave now,
sir.
Uh,
but how much is being egalitarian?
Yeah,
well that's okay.
I'm not that either.
I'm not an egalitarian,
but,
um,
you're not,
no.
Oh,
hold on.
Too many topics at once.
Jesus Christ.
We go off a lot of branches here.
I know.
It's,
I love it.
Um,
where was I going?
Oh,
this is what you did was you identified and I think actually we,
I talked about this the first time I was here,
which is that,
you know,
this is what's,
to me at the heart of this is the appalling irony at the heart of contemporary
feminism as practice by self-defined feminists.
Okay.
Many,
not all guys.
I'm not general.
I'm not saying all feminists are like this,
but I'd say it's certainly it's the dominant strain right now,
which is that it is at its heart patriarchal,
which it treats women as vulnerable,
weak,
powerless,
incapable of making their own way in this world and uh,
treats men as the not just forget about the men.
Forget about how they treat men.
It's how they treat women that's sexist.
It says that they need protection from the state,
which is run by usually men,
but it's also this other institution or you know,
college presidents need to protect these women from 19 year old boys who want to
have sex with them.
Same thing.
They're constantly calling for women to be protected by these institutions.
The state by men.
It is patriarchal and sexist right at the,
at the heart of it.
And same thing with family court and divorce law and all that stuff.
That's how they get treated.
They get treated like they're the ones who need to be taken care of by a man.
It is,
it's like 1950s sexism.
It's like madmen sexism.
That's what,
that's what most feminists are calling for now.
Well,
I disagree when you talking about child rearing because I think that
child support is,
should be absolutely mandatory and it's very important.
And if a woman is the only one raising the kids on their own,
not only does she need the money for food and housing,
but also probably for someone to babysit her kids.
There's a lot,
a lot of factors involved and totally agree.
And if the man's not in the scene like yeah,
he owes money.
Yeah,
for sure.
He has a responsibility.
And as a father,
at the very least,
that's,
you should,
what you should be doing is contributing financially.
I totally agree.
But not oppose.
My problem is alimony.
Alimony's weird.
Yeah.
That makes no sense at all.
It's weird.
Well,
it's,
I don't think it's a bad thing if someone like say,
how about this?
Say,
um,
let's turn around.
Say you had a wife who was wealthy and she was taking care of you while you're
going through school and she promised that she was going to fund you all the way
through your phd program.
She was going to give you money.
So you didn't have to worry about anything but your education.
And then once you got out,
then you guys could share income.
But somewhere along the way she decided she was done with you and then you're
fucked.
But during the middle of this program that you have to pay for,
I don't think it's unreasonable to say that she should give you until you can
figure your own system out so you don't have to quit your phd program and go get
a job somewhere and get an apartment and a car.
I don't think that's,
that's it.
I don't think that's unreasonable.
What's unreasonable is saying that because you guys were together for a certain
amount of time,
she has to pay you for the rest of your life.
Sure.
That's insanity.
And that's current.
That's real.
I agree.
That's the second.
But should that be legal though?
So that'd be legally enforced.
Should courts be deciding how long the alimony is paid?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's the key.
I don't know.
How has that happened?
Like what?
What's the motivation behind that for the courts to succumb to give into,
just explained it to you.
It's sexism,
it's patriarchy.
It's,
and the feminists are,
are playing along with it.
That's it.
It's this like,
yeah,
it's this idea that women can't make words though.
I mean isn't the courts,
aren't there?
Are a lot of men fall in those courts?
D I mean,
why are they allowing all this stuff and most of them think basically like
feminists or at least they,
they are expected to behave and make decisions.
Like feminists,
feminism has become dominant in that way.
In our culture going on for decades,
laws have existed long before feminism.
So prevalent article,
that's my point.
It went from sexist patriarchy,
those laws.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So feminism is basically continuing that stuff in its name.
Matching up the definition.
Let me say really loud and clear.
There have always been feminists who hate this stuff as much as that you and I
do.
Camille Paglia many,
right?
And they have been loud and clear about this for a long,
long time and I love them.
And they're my heroes.
And I've learned from them,
and this is,
I've learned these things from them.
Okay.
Um,
but the ones who really are powerful and dominant in the media,
the ones we hear from the public intellectuals,
the academics and government leaders,
the people who end up in the White House,
you know,
Obama's staff in HHS,
health and human services,
and the Department of Education,
it became very clear to me that all the sexual assault laws and rules that came
out of there,
they were,
they were coming right out of colleges and they were really of that they were of
the sort of college feminist movement.
They were the ones who set that letter in 2011 that made it basically mandatory
for colleges to set up these kangaroo courts for sexual abuse,
sexual assault cases,
all the nonsense.
You and I talked about here a couple years ago.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I got anybody interested review those or earlier podcasts about your college,
about oxide as many colleges.
Yeah.
But you know,
there's a whole backlash now,
right?
There's a huge,
it's all turning back.
And I knew he was going to happen right now.
They're completely being decimated.
There's hundreds,
maybe even thousands of men who are suing in court,
and many of them are winning right now for good reason,
because there was no due process because they weren't allowed to,
you know,
ask questions.
Poor boy,
the mattress boy or that girl put a fucking mattress on her back,
drags around campus,
and then took her graduation speech with a mattress.
They went on stage with a mattress.
I mean,
the whole thing was so fucking crazy.
Oh yeah.
My uh,
yeah.
This is fantastic.
Sex worker activist named Christine Pereira isn't Vegas.
She said she tweeted something like,
when that happened,
he said,
fuck you,
mattress girl.
For those of us who've really been raped,
you're a fucking disgrace.
Ooh.
She went off.
It was something like that.
Yeah,
and it was,
yeah,
but that girl seems pretty crazy.
That mattress girl.
Yeah.
That was an extreme example.
Then boys suing that school,
they're all suing and many of them are winning and I don't know what happened in
those cases.
I don't need to know what happened in mattress girl for sure.
For sure.
I know that there's all kinds of evidence,
so sure.
Looks like it didn't happen the way she said it did.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
And I never will.
We will never know.
You can't know.
But what we do know for absolute sure is that there's been terrible or no due
process in those cases.
Right.
And so that's the problem.
I mean that basically the accuser gets to win every time.
Imagine if that was our legal system writ large.
Right.
Joe,
you stole $1 million from yesterday.
All right.
Put Him in jail.
Right?
That's basically what's happening.
Exactly.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it got so crazy that even rolling stone printed a false rape case that
that gang rape case and Uva k staunching,
which is just how did a company that's been in the journalism business as long
as they've been,
how did they fuck that up?
Yeah,
that was,
that was the turning point.
I think when that came out that it was completely made up.
I think since then it's,
it started to turn.
So that's good that things like that happen so that you realize why it's
important to have checks and balances and that people had reaffirms this idea of
real journalism is important to have your facts in order to have checks and,
and,
and double check things and make sure,
you know,
what the fuck you're printing.
I think it's good for society.
I think it's terrible for John Doe all the John Doe's out there,
all those men who were accused and expelled and had their names ruined and their
careers ruined,
right.
College careers destroyed and all that stuff,
right?
I think,
but yes,
you,
but also,
even if you're exonerated,
the emotional turmoil that you go through,
there's no way they can reward you for that.
There are,
or compensate you for that rather.
So that,
but that is part of that whole thing,
as I said before,
is part of this sort of ironic feminist patriarchy.
Yeah.
Ideology,
right.
Which is,
you know,
we need protection.
We can't,
we can't cause it because we can't say no to men.
We can't stop them by saying,
no,
we need,
you know,
w we,
we need help just there.
We need to do,
we need the college president to save us or the cops or someone.
It's,
it's an incredible,
um,
well then there's this also this thing where two people are drinking and if the
two people are drinking,
the girl is getting raped.
There you go.
Same thing.
The guy's not getting rid of.
The women are incapable of controlling themselves when they're drunk.
It's sexist as hell.
Exactly.
Because the man's drunk too.
But it doesn't,
if somehow or another,
it doesn't matter,
even if they're both like sending texts back and forth.
Do you have condoms?
Like the Occidental Kitchen,
patriarchal women,
our children,
their daughters need to be taken care of by dad.
And the sons are men.
Yeah.
Even though they're just same age and they're boys.
They have full agency.
Yeah.
And the women,
the women are daughters.
Yeah.
It is sexist.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
yeah.